today playstation reacts to this week's
big xbox news and call of duty deals
with some hiccups
sony has responded to microsoft's insane
proposed acquisition of activision
blizzard a deal that sends shockwaves
through the industry and one that could
hurt playstation one of the biggest
questions going forward should
microsoft's deal go through is whether
or not games like call of duty will
become xbox exclusive or stay on all
platforms a spokesperson for sony told
the wall street journal quote we expect
that microsoft will abide by contractual
agreements and continue to ensure
activision games are multi-platform
activision recently published the
prospectus of its deal with microsoft
and there are multiple sections
pertaining to what happens with regards
to quote existing partner agreements the
quick takeaway is that activision
blizzard said it will honor all existing
commitments when the deal closes it went
on to say that quote as with microsoft's
acquisition of minecraft we have no
intent to remove any content from
platforms where it exists today if you
didn't know microsoft acquired mojang
and the minecraft series and it
continues to release the games on
playstation and nintendo instead of
making them exclusive to xbox for
microsoft's bethesda buyout microsoft is
honoring existing contracts which is why
death loop and ghostwire tokyo are
playstation exclusives at launch but
future titles like starfield and the
elder scrolls 6 are expected to be xbox
exclusives some have suggested that call
of duty war zone might remain
multi-platform with the yearly mainline
games becoming xbox exclusive this is
just speculation though and no official
announcements have been made
and speaking of warzone activision has
delayed the launch of call of duty
vanguard and war zone pacific's season
2. the new season is now scheduled to go
live on monday february 14th which is
also valentine's day so a lot of call of
duty fans are gonna have to either go
romantic dinner or new season of war
zone or combine the two romantic dinner
in war zone in a blog post activision
said it's spending the additional
development time to release more updates
and optimizations for vanguard war zone
pacific black ops cold war and modern
warfare 2019 to get those games into
better shape the company also promised
to do more to communicate better with
call of duty fans
and while call of duty war zone's
ricochet anti-cheat has been recently
praised for keeping cheaters at bay
hackers are now flying cars around the
map call of duty players have dubbed the
flying cars as the harry potter meta in
war zone and this isn't the first time
land vehicles have gone airborne in the
battle royale cheaters use this tactic
to disrupt matches on warzone's verdance
map last year using hacks to turn the
game's vehicles and atvs into flying
machines these cars can be a huge
distraction and a hard sheet to counter
reddit user sean fitz12 shared a clip of
a flying car during a match on rebirth
island and wrote
the harry potter car isn't funny at all
but i mean
it's pretty hilarious and maybe i'm just
saying that because it hasn't happened
to me yet i haven't played warzone in a
while but let me know if you're dealing
with it and what you want to happen with
the whole maybe call of duty will be
xbox exclusive maybe it won't be where
do you stand on that i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
you